and with plenty more strikes to come
from train drivers to ambulance workers
civil servants to University lecturers
there's no deal in sight which is sunac
has been in office for 100 days and the
strikes aren't his only headache with a
growing row over bullying claims against
his Deputy Prime Minister so lots for us
to get stuck into as we bring you takes
from all sides over the next 60 minutes
how would he feel if one of his friends
or relatives was being forced to work
for a bully simply because the man at
the top was too weak to do anything
about it
okay
well things got very heated over those
bullying allegations against the Deputy
Prime Minister and what his boss should
do about it
it's typical of him Mr Speaker declining
to lead sitting on the fence carping
from the sidelines
and and never standing up for a
principle that matters
typically civil premises questions I
think we can all agree uh there we'll
hear one from one of Richard Cena's
cabinet allies later on the program and
here he is the chancellor of the duchy
of Lancaster uh
hopefully here he is here he is there it
is uh Oliver dad and we'll be talking to
him on the show uh this evening from
labor we'll be talking to their Shadow
leveling up Minister Alex Norris on the
program and we'll also have the smps
Kirsty Blackman
plus we'll be speaking to Christine
Charles dean of the liberal Democrats
much more besides all on the take
[Music]
hello good evening well that hundred day
honeymoon hasn't really worked out for
Rishi CNAC after nadims are Haru sake on
Sunday there have been more strikes
gloomy economic news and calls for his
Deputy Prime Minister to be suspended so
let's crack on here are some of the
highlights of the week so far
the Prime Minister will lay out a
two-year emergency care plan for the NHS
in England today it consists of loads of
different things including working from
home for some NHS workers my point to
you is people watching this will think
that that is not good enough and do you
accept it's going to take years to fix
the NHS of course it's not good enough
of course gosh what happened in December
was not was not great the senior U.S
general has privately told the defense
secretary Ben Wallace that the British
army is no longer regarded a top level
fighting force does need urgent
recapitalization and that's why we're
investing it I'm not going to sort of
say look over here look at the red
arrows and shoot me the color I'm going
to actually say that's what's going on
behind the scenes and we're going to try
and fix it at one point and said you
know Boris I don't want to hurt you but
uh with a missile it would only take a
minute or something like that you know
now the UK economy is expected to be the
only economy in the developed world to
shrink this year so Russia there with
0.3 growth the UK minus 0.6 it's pretty
striking isn't it the UK is also its
employment level have not recovered to
pre-pandemic levels today's RMF report
reflect your economic plan mistrust if
the chancellor had ideas answers or
courage he would be here today but he is
not warning everyone the education
secretary Jillian Keegan gave her
message to teach us this morning when
she appeared on our program and is not
budging on pay and I'm not going to just
go in and say here you go we will do
inflation plus whatever
um it would be economically incoherent
to do that
the turnout is magnificent and it shows
the strength and feeling that teachers
have the party opposite would do well to
say that the strikes are wrong and we
should be backing our school children
[Music]
well on a day like today it's good to
speak to someone in government who is
particularly close to Rishi sunak and
Oliver Dowden it's one of his key allies
and runs the cabinet office I spoke to
the chancellor at the duchy of Lancaster
a little earlier
rushi sunak is marking 100 days as prime
minister how do you think it's gone well
I think we've made a good and strong
start the first thing we had to do was
restore economic stability and we've
done that and if you look for example in
relation to projections of where
interest rates are going those curves
are coming downwards we've set out a
clear plan whether it's to stop the
boats and we've outlined plans for that
whether it's to make sure that we get
waiting lists down whether it's to make
sure we have inflation that's absolutely
crucial or to reduce debt or to get the
economy growing we've got a clear sense
of direction prime minister's rolling up
his sleeves and getting on with the job
the one thing you haven't done though is
get a grip on strikes you know today we
have teachers walking out schools
closing we've got more strikes in the
NHS next week what's going on well first
of all in respect of the the school
strikes and I know many parents and I
myself will be worried by it I'd like to
pay tribute to all the the heads and
indeed the teachers actually it's the
case that almost half of schools have
remained fully open and only 10 percent
have been totally closed and that's
thanks the really hard work of the head
teachers and indeed the teachers
themselves
about 30 have been on strike the rest of
them have have been in schools and
that's so important given the the kind
of disruption that kids have already
seen with covid it's just not fair to
deprive them of more education you think
it's not fair then for teachers to be on
strike I don't think it's the right way
to go about these things no the the
government the door is open the
government is engaging I'll just give
you one example of how we we managed to
do this the unions came to the education
secretary before Christmas and they said
look we need more money for for
Education we need two billion pounds
more the education secretary and the
chancellor work together to give that
for this coming year and next year so
we've we've shown willing you say it's
not fair for teachers to be on strike
but actually if you look at this chart
that I hope you should be able to show
you this shows real term pay rise since
2011 not by going if you're a train
driver but look at the bottom there
teachers
many teachers will be thinking actually
it is very fair to be going on strike
because it's the only way we can get
what we want well first of all I
understand teachers concerns and indeed
I understand concerns of people across
the public sector
yes we've had a big surge in inflation
uh course principally by the war of
Ukraine but covert and other factors and
in response that everyone public and
private sector
may I just finished these points over
now has seen their pay squeeze now in
response to that we can't give inflation
busting pay Rises but we are taking
board medicine and actually if you look
at what we've done with teachers those
on the lowest pay we've increased their
pay to 30 000 pounds that's a pay rise
of almost nine percent and for a teacher
that's on the kind of median wage was
about 39 000 they're getting a five
percent right now I know that's not as
much as they want but we went through an
independent process to get there so we
are we are taking action but sadly we
cannot give those inflation busting
Rises not just because of the cost
associated with it but also because we
need to make sure that we don't build in
inflation into the economy because
inflation is the thing that makes
everyone poorer okay I mean I guess what
teachers would say in response to that
is that look if you look at the charts
if you look at how their pay has
suffered over the last year then they
are the ones who haven't been getting
pay risers that keep up with the rest
other employees as well
I know how hard education you know you
talked about the importance of it you
must know how important it is yeah and
it matters enormously to me and I know
the the hard work that you so I always
say that uh I know a huge debt of
gratitude to the the school that I I
went to and actually we have taken into
account some of those pay pressures
that's why there's been a nine percent
pay rise for those on the the lowest pay
of course I understand they wanted to go
further but we do have to to weigh up
the wider considerations we were talking
at the beginning about how the first
hundred days it has gone and you made a
big play on the economy and how it did a
good start and strong start on the
economy
um at the same time though you know if
you actually look this week the IMF at
forecast the UK would be the worst
performing major economy this year
whereas even than Russia I mean for the
man which is unac who's pitching himself
as the guy who can sort out the economy
so that's not the forecast you need is
it well first of all I would say that
the IMF and if you listen to the the
press conferences they had they said we
weren't making the right decisions we
were going in the right direction if you
look at those numbers the UK has
actually had this unique pressure on the
one hand where a European economy so
we've had the pressure of the Russian
oil and gas price Rises that's created a
lot of inflation pressure that for
example has been less so in somewhere
like the us but we also have a tight
labor market in the way that the US has
and other countries don't so we are
under a lot of pressure right now but
actually if you look across the board
say if you look from 22 to 24 over this
sort of a kind of longer time frame our
growth rate I think is in excess of
places like Japan and France and there's
about the same places as as the us if
you take a slightly longer term view
we're in a much better position what's
your um plan to turn it around then well
the first thing we have to do is we've
got to get inflation under control
because inflation is the thing that
makes everyone poorer and it entrenches
economic uh instability so we're making
starting to make progress on that that's
why we set this target of halving
inflation and then we also need to
upskill people we need to get a dynamic
and Innovative economy so we need
investment in New Life Sciences new
technologies and you've seen some of the
announcements from the the government in
relation to that and actually I do think
there's an opportunity this is three
years since we've left the European
Union to seize opportunities like for
example uh data laws I reform those when
I was a digital secretary we're
reforming procurement laws now in in my
current role so we've got to seize those
opportunities I guess problem is that it
feels doesn't it like Rishi sunak is
getting sidetracked by other issues
right we talked about uh you know
nadeem's Hardware a lot in recent weeks
another thing is Dominic Robb under
investigation for bullying allegations
now political editor Beth Rigby a source
telling her today that this summer so
before he was prime minister before he
appointed Dominic arrived to his cabinet
he was made aware of concerns around
Dominic Robb's conduct what did Rishi
sunak know first of all I should say I
don't think the Prime Minister has been
distracted he's set out a a clear plan
to halve inflation reduce the debt so
the way that I described we delivered an
Autumn statement we're delivering a plan
on the NHS in respect of the allocations
in relation to uh the the Deputy Prime
Minister it wasn't the case that the
Prime Minister received any formal
complaints before they started however
they did emerge subsequently and that's
why he's taking it very seriously and
asked Adam Tolley who's a very very
senior lawyer someone with employment
law experience to look into this
properly and to get to the bottom of it
it feels to me like you're using a very
specific phrase here
that Richardson was not aware of
specific formal allegations what was he
aware of well I think the the right way
to do this is to say if there's a formal
complaint we will take it seriously
this is a really important point which
is that for us for the government to be
able to investigate this we need to
understand that there is a formal
complaint when those formal complaints
came to light he asked Adam Tolley to
investigate it I think that's the right
due process way of doing this it's a
similar to what we did in respect of the
the chairman of the the conservative
party when these allegations are made we
look into them properly and we take
action that's exactly what the prime
minister is going to do I feel like
that's an extremely eloquent argument
for youth program process but my
specific question is
what did Rishi sunak know around Dominic
Robb's conduct in the summer well the
Prime Minister has been clear on this
and was clear in Parliament again today
that he wasn't aware of formal
allegations
against him and formal uh complaints
against uh the the Deputy Prime Minister
and I don't I think that this goes I
mean you characterize it as sort of
talking very kind to say eloquently
about due process but that that is that
that is the way that we should address
these things it a formal complaint is a
trigger for these things to be properly
investigated and that's exactly what the
Prime Minister has done by getting Adam
tolly uh into it it you you might want
your passion I'm asking is so the
question I'm asking is so simple and I
feel that we're getting a very careful
formula of words to something that is
quite different you're talking about
what Richard C Nick was not aware of he
was not aware of formal complaints what
was he aware of but the the reason why
I'm saying this is because you would
expect that if there are formal
complaints then they would be properly
uh investigated I'm I don't know the the
the details of all sort of things that
uh that in the way that um you said that
Beth Rigby had described didn't have any
of those uh details but what I do know
is that when we get to a point where
there's a formal complaint made it's
right that it should be investigated and
that's what he's done
um you haven't got a party chairman at
the minute after Nadine zahari was sat
she mentioned him a moment ago
you've done the job before
would you do it again you're tempting me
into speculating about decisions that
are for the the Prime Minister snake all
I can say is that I'm very happy in my
role as transfer the doctor of Lancaster
I have an enormous entry whether it's
dealing with government uh resilience
whether it's dealing with bringing
government together to to meet those
kind of goals that I've set out that's
plenty for me to be getting on with
you're being talked about the guardian
quotes one MP he knows the donors he can
do the attack dog role he can do the
strategy would you do I'm very happy
where I am right now but I'm not going
to try and prejudge any decisions
um you also resigned as party chair at
the time uh partly I think it's fair to
say you because you're unhappy with the
leadership of Boris Johnson it feels
like he's in the headlines an awful lot
at the minute he's doing an interview
with Nadine uh Doris he has been given a
million pound donation not the sort of
money you usually get for quietly
sitting on the back benches he's still
generating headlines because of this
relationship with the BBC chairman
it's in asset to the conservative party
yes I mean I think Bryce is a a
tremendous political force and I've I've
always had huge respect for his his
political uh abilities and I know he's
very much committed to politics and I'm
very glad that he's staying in
Parliament and committed to doing that
what would you say to conservative MPS
you might be looking at the current
polling getting very worried worried
about the May elections uh worried about
the general election and thinking maybe
we need a Boris bounce
or I would say to to those MPS is what I
hear from my constituents and I hear up
and down the country which is they don't
want the government to be obsessing
about Westminster to be obsessing about
polls they want us to be getting on with
the job and dealing with the challenges
that they face in their lives whether
that's inflation whether it's the NHS
backlogs whether it's small boats we've
got a clear plan to be dealing with
those things the five priorities the
Prime Minister set out we're going to be
focused relentlessly on that and if we
can deliver on those things when the
election comes it has to come by the end
of of next year that's the time for
those kind of debates okay thank you
very much thanks
a cabinet office Minister Oliver dad and
their potential next party chairman uh
we'll have to see uh let's get labors at
take now uh shall we on the news around
today we're joined live by the party
Shadow leveling up Minister Alex Norris
thanks for being with us thank you in
the studio
um I know you were listening to the
interview with um Oliver dowdon there
what did you make about of the exchange
on what Rishi Cena knew and when about
the dominant Rob allegations Oliver dad
on there saying look he wasn't aware of
any formal allegations of course this
was a theme that came out today's prime
minister's questions Kirsten was pushing
the Prime Minister on it I think you had
it right Sophie when you said that
they're using a very specific phrase
about formal allegations which I think
perhaps speaks volumes about what other
things might have been known of course
we're going to have to have this inquiry
take place but the reporting that's come
out of it so far is really concerning
this is the person you know Richie soon
act right-hand man and you know there's
some real questions to be answered here
I guess it is important isn't it do you
think that there is a tendency between
the media and politics to prejudge these
kind of things you know you you can't
find someone guilty without having due
process can you no you have to do things
right but I would also say and you know
this government Richie sunach just as
Boris Johnson's did let's just perhaps
didn't have quite the same time to do
the same thing have a habit of relying
on these inquiries there are some things
you shouldn't need in independent ethics
advisor to tell you about and so that
will come out in terms of what Richard
sunat really did know because there are
some things as I say that wouldn't need
that test and instead you'd look out and
say well actually this isn't someone who
should be taking High offers just as
perhaps someone who has had to resign
for leaking State Secrets shouldn't be
but is it is it right to say someone
shouldn't have be taking High office if
you don't have any evidence in front of
you I mean surely it is important to
have a process there of course the due
process is right the question here is
what did Rishi sunak know and you know
they are using a very narrow definition
of what he knew which does obviously ask
her the questions so there's a really
easy way to clear this up he can give a
candid answer he wouldn't do it prime
minister's questions obviously Oliver
wouldn't do that and the sooner they do
that you know the sooner you know get
this out of the way and just let the
process carry on okay okay now I'm Keen
to talk about the other really big story
today which is the strikes uh teachers
of course uh walking out schools up and
down the country are closing uh Oliver
dad and said it's not fair on children
who've already missed so much education
because of the pandemic do you think
he's right I'm not sure that would have
been the phrase I would have used I
think is a sadness every single day of
lost education for our young people is a
terrible thing especially given
obviously the really difficult couple of
years they've had as well so this is an
exceptionally sad situation it shouldn't
have come to this but I don't think the
government in a position to start
talking about fairness on it
um the National Education Union say that
they want a fully funded above inflation
pay rise so effectively we know where
inflation is that means double-digit pay
rise doesn't it 10 with labor grant that
well it's not the first time a trade
Union would start with that sort of
request what we would be doing in
government is getting around the table
something you know Oliver talks about
debates and discussions that happened in
December that weren't even about pay we
would be round the table they would
start at that point we would have those
discussions and would come to a deal
that worked for teachers work for the
the national exchequer and got more
importantly the school's open look I get
that you say that you'd be round the
table but but what I'm trying to get at
is what would you say when you were
around the table because saying we get
around the table that's the easy
business and we'd come up with a deal
that everyone's happy with that's also
very easy to say but would you give them
a double digit pay rise well it wouldn't
be fair for me tonight to be trying to
negotiate with the unions from
opposition from this chair of course it
wouldn't you know there are a whole
degree of things that go into that
calculation you know the nation's
finances are important part of that
things that from opposition we can't do
you know Sophie very well because lots
of my colleagues tell you this that
you'll get a fully funded you know
Manifesto from us in due course but to
pull this out of that and ask for a
specific number well of course I can't
do that tomorrow you know what you know
I'm not expecting you to kind of
freelance and give us a number but I'm
just kind of wondering why haven't labor
got a stronger line on this this is the
issue affecting the country right now
we're seeing like the biggest strikes
that you know Generations teachers
walking out nurses ambulance workers and
labor are just not giving us any
ballpark figure on what is a fair pay
rise because shape the debate I know
about boiling down the debate to just
one fraction about success for example
hey isn't it well no it's one hospital
it's also about workloads if you talk to
any of the union leaders whether it's
you know the nursing Union or the
teachings Union as we do on programs
like this they say yes about pay but
it's also about workload and we've made
a commitment that if we abolish abolish
private schools charity status we could
have six and a half thousand more
teachers that's a part of it granted not
all of it but what you can't do from
opposition is resolve things and we have
that again at pmqs you can raise the
debate you can shape the debate and
that's I think you know what some union
leaders for example you know talking to
Sharon Graham if you know it she says it
would be helpful if they'd come out with
a pay figure because it helped shape the
debate well we won't always please our
colleagues and friends in the unions
we're going to do what we think is best
for the country what we know for sure
and this is where I probably take
exception to the shaping the debate
characterization is that actually what
did we see in pmqs today what did we see
from Oliver the government want to use
these strikes as a way of dividing
people a way of getting political
capital that's not actually how pay
disagreements and how work disagreements
get resolved they only get resolved by
dialogue and I know that's not quite
perhaps as eye-catching but it is the
only way that this will be resolved
that's what we would be doing and that's
what any frankly sensible government
should be doing okay so you say you'll
resolve the debate but you won't tell us
how well through negotiations it's the
only way and sometimes how that sausage
gets made I mean I'm a former Union
organizer as you know so for those can
be difficult conversations but you can't
do them from a megaphone you can't do
them from the dispatch box of a House of
Commons you need to be together around
the table government the government just
won't do that you wouldn't give the
double digit paywise that's would you
that's the honest truth of it well as I
said I can't set pay in in the studio
tonight and you know a car okay uh now
you are of course in the department or
the shadow department for leveling up
it's a year since that at leveling up
white paper you know where the
governments set out how it planned to
make good on its Manifesto commitment to
level up how is it going well you know
we will remember a year ago Michael Gove
was touring the studios I think he was
in this very Studio we do at some point
Sophie with his leveling up white paper
saying that this was the the kind of the
defining mission of the government to
tackle Regional inequalities and that
they would be held to account and that
they would report every year it's a year
on obviously there's no report we think
that's wrong they need to be honest with
the British people Regional inequalities
actually have widened you know public
the viewers will know you can't get in
cgp we're losing bus routes train
services are complete Mass that's what
leveling up is and it's time for Michael
Gove to come clean about that and Lisa
and is written to Michael Gabe I think
that's right that's right at least it's
written today to ask Michael to make
that and make good on that promise
whatever you know the wise and where
falls on leveling up he will have his
views we have ours but that was a
commitment to report every year here's a
year let's report and have an honest
debate so that people this country can
make that assessment as to whether we
really are tackling the inequalities
that hold us back there's been quite a
lot of debate in recent weeks about the
kind of regions when it comes to
leveling up and as some some people
saying that look you know too much money
is going to the South Southeast do you
think that's fair or do you think that
look there is deprivation in the
Southeast as well yeah I think ever
making this North versus South making
this kind of everyone versus London in
the Southeast is quite a reductive
characterization because all you say
there is poverty in many if not all
communities Coastal communities so the
East Coast they've got some significant
challenges what we think it should be
about is about devolving power to all
you know all areas not just the ones
that the government think are good
enough to have those deals and then the
resources rather than having this Hunger
Games funding where you all have to bid
in some of you weren't even allowed to
win and you didn't even know that and
then a bit of money comes out on unclear
criteria let's get all that money
together 300 different funds across
government and let's invest that in our
communities in a more reliable way
that's targeted their needs I think
that's what that's Justice and most
importantly it'll mean that we all our
Nations and regions of the UK can make a
contribution where so many at the moment
are written off okay interesting to talk
thanks very much for coming into the
studio today
there you go that is Labor's take on
strikes and also of course leveling up
one of those issues I'm sure isn't going
to go anywhere soon well we've had the
government's take we have had Labor's
take as well let's to get the take of
our Deputy political editor at Sam
Coates who is on the program for us
today and we've been talking quite a lot
about Dominic Robb uh this evening what
do you make of the interview so far
well I was very struck by the interview
with Oliver Dowden because this all
comes against a backdrop of problems
mounting up for Rishi sooner you
mentioned Dominic Raab you've got the
Northern Ireland protocol you've got
strikes are the only thing the only
thing that Oliver Dowden here we are
three months in can say is going well is
that they calm the economic turmoil that
was a hangover from the Liz truss era
because Richardson that wants to be a
problem solver and there aren't many
problems that he really solved to date
and that's where we get to the issue of
Dominic Rob now earlier in the week at
the weekend on Sunday you obviously had
the departure of Nadim zahawi and that
has left a vacancy in the cabinet an
unfulfilled cabinet reshuffle and now
questions about the Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Raab who was uh who's
been filling the headlines in the last
uh 36 hours and Oliver Dad no doubt used
a very careful formulation he talked
about no formal complaints being raised
with the Prime Minister that raises the
question which he did about what the
prime minister new but let's turn this
question on its head why might Rishi
sunak find it hard to get rid of this
man Dominic Robb he's been in government
many years and he was accused by some of
bullying allegations and I think the
answer is that this man is actually
pretty important to Rishi sinak is it
he's in the kitchen cabinet the kind of
inner core I think that he relies on him
for his political judgment he's a
hardcore brexiteer who played a key role
in some of those brexit debates and the
two men iconic place it's not like Nadim
zahawi cutting the chord on this is
quite difficult some are asking why
can't Dominic Robb make it easy for
Rishi sunak and actually walk it's
interesting you were saying there about
the importance of Dominic Rob and I
remember you know during those really
bitter leadership campaigns right and at
the beginning all the momentum was with
Richie sunac and then suddenly it
switched to Liz truss and what you saw
then was people piling behind Liz trust
because they wanted a place in her
cabinet right so they come into Studios
like this and talk about how great this
trust was and criticize Rishi neck and
that one person who was on team soon
like the whole time was Dominic Rupp
right so he played a huge role defending
him when the rest of the tide was
turning against Russia Cena and and
Dominic Rob's got a lot of heat for that
because he was back in 2011 2012 Paul
and Liz trusses gang they were writing
Unchained Britannia together and yet
he's as it was switch sides stuck with
Richie sunac didn't play any part and
wasn't invited into Liz truss's
government because he was part of a
different faction and factionalism
Sophie is still really important inside
this conservative party and Dominic Raab
was on the prime minister's team and
that's why it's so much harder for
Richardson to let go which is why people
are asking tonight for the good of prime
minister why can't he just walk uh
interesting stuff uh Sam we'll get your
take uh later in the program that's more
wide-ranging subjects as well but always
interesting to hear your kind of first
reaction to the interviews so far you're
watching at the take we're live here in
Westminster for you this evening up next
we have the S P's Kirsty Blackman
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you are watching the take well now time
to get the take from the s p we're
joined by the party's cabinet office
spokesperson Kirsty Blackman lovely to
have you on the program good evening
today it feels like we should start with
strikes um a huge issue you know we've
seen teachers walking out across the
country and in Scotland I think they're
on the third week of rolling strikes but
what would be a fair pay rise for
teachers
I think we need to think about this in
terms of the cost of living you know the
cost of living is increasing massively
and I can completely understand why
teachers and everybody else are looking
at their pay packets and thinking this
is not going to stretch you know our
electricity or gas has gone through the
roof and how are we going to make this
work
um I think you know it is important to
make sure that people stay around the
table and actually it's also important
to note that it's not just about pay in
all of these strikes that are happening
you know people are striking about
conditions as well as pay we want to not
make sure that the focus is not entirely
on pay because there are issues other
than that
um they want teachers want a 10 pay rise
right sort of keep up with inflation
um should they not get that
the problem that we've got in Scotland
is that um the way that our budgets work
we've got to operate with a fixed budget
so we've got to balance the budget
um on an annual basis
um and the problem is that if
Westminster doesn't make pay offers that
are reasonable then the Barnard
consequentials don't come through we
don't get an uplift in our budget and we
are having to you know make decisions
about what do we want to cut in order to
provide the increases so I can
understand completely why they're asking
for this
um but I can also understand why the
Scottish government is not able to say
here you go this is this is what you're
asking for and we can deliver it because
delivering it in years particularly hard
I mean I guess you know the Westminster
government could say similar things
right that look they'd love to be able
to give teachers a 10 pay rise but you
know what does that mean how do you
afford it what do you cut what you tax
these are the difficult decisions right
I mean they are the difficult decisions
but the Westminster government doesn't
have to operate by law a balanced budget
it doesn't have that requirement
basically saying that you know you could
run out some more debts so even though
we're spending more on debt interests
than education I think I think that they
could sit around the table with the
teachers and actually come up with a
reasonable pay offer
um and a reasonable offer in order to
improve the conditions so we're already
in a situation in Scotland where we've
got many um more teachers per 100 000
children for example many more schools
per
um 100 000 children we're we're doing
better we're putting more money we're
spending significantly more in education
per person
um in Scotland already if the
Westminster government even would match
what we're doing then there would have
been a significantly better position and
this was the year that Nicholas sturgeon
wanted to see a second Independence
referendum
what's the latest on that have you
effectively like given up on that
happening so we're having a special
conference and our special conferences
coming up
um or in February now so next month
um and the SMP special conference is
going to talk about the way forward for
that because obviously you know the
Supreme Court result although we
absolutely accept it was obviously
disappointing because it would have been
this this is the year that we were going
to have our independence referendum and
clearly I'm disappointed about that
we're still we're still going to have an
independence reference and people are
still going to get the opportunity to
have a say in whatever form that looks
like what does that mean though is it
are you gonna when you say people will
get the opportunity to have a say could
it be effectively watered down that
you're going to try and make the next
election uh de facto referendum so we'll
we will I I don't want to prejudge
what's going to happen at this special
conference um of party members and I
don't want to pre-judge what the outcome
of that is going to be but we're you
know it's going to be put to members how
do you want to see this happen how do
you want to see the Scottish people
being able to have their say and that
discussion will be had and then a
decision will be made as a result but
you know we've got a mandate for this
but you can't
you can't General a new one an election
to you know
it's not the same as a binary referendum
is it no it's not the same but it's not
a preferred option a preferred option is
a referendum but you know we're doing
kind of meaningless and the the thing is
that we don't have the power to do that
you know we don't have the power to to
have this referendum that's what was
decided at the um Supreme Court we would
like to do that that is very much you
know the the first thing that we would
like to do it is um something that we've
been given a mandate for by this people
of Scotland and Westminster have said no
you know I mean the ball is really in
their core on this what are they going
to do what is Scotland's way out of this
if Scotland's if we're in a voluntary
Union right
Scotland needs to have a way to have it
say what is the way to Harvard sea
Westminster haven't adequately answered
that question and how do we get out of
this Union if we want to you know other
than continuing to vote SNP every
election I mean I guess what people in
Westminster would say you know the
conservatives would say is that you have
had a say in a referendum that your side
lost we did have a referendum in 2014
before brexit brexit changed everything
it's made it more difficult hasn't it
because you know what would you do in
terms of you know currency in terms of a
border with the rest of the United
Kingdom it's made it more complicated
the the biggest couple of things that
brexit has done actually in terms of
Scottish independence is well they've
it's had a major impact
um to the tune of 100 billion pounds
annually on the British economy which is
a significant problem you know we're
going to have the worst growth in the G7
so we are suffering as a result of
brexit but also Scotland voted to remain
in the EU we voted to remain in the EU
and yet our voice wasn't heard in that
because England is bigger motivated to
remain in the UK well yes because we
were told this is the only way to remain
in the EU you know that's what that's
what Better Together said Better
Together said to us if you want to
remain in the EU you have to vote no in
the independence referendum and then we
had a brexit referendum and we're
dragged out of the European Union it's
an awful lot of people are deeply
unhappy with that an awful lot of people
have changed from being no voters in
2014 to being yes vultures now because
they're very pro-eu okay we'll have to
see the result of the special conference
uh great to have you on the program I
think the first time yes lovely team
thank you very much uh you are watching
uh the take with safety Ridge we're live
here in Westminster up next we'll be
talking to Christine Jardine from the
Liverpool Democrats
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westman so
you're watching the take now on the
program we often like to pick out a
particular promises question and talk to
the person who asked it and there was
quite a moment earlier in the House of
Commons that I want to show you when the
kind of usually quite raucous session
eventually fell quiet as the liberal
Democrat Christine Jardine asked a
question about breast cancer and said
that she wanted to see more government
support for careless let's have a little
listen to The Exchange
uh thank you very much Mr Deputy speaker
this past week
[Applause]
I blame the painkillers
apologies Mr Speaker and thank you
um this past weekend I uh visited a
charity which was hosting an exhibition
in my constituency about metastatic
breast cancer
um which claims 31 lives
each day in the United Kingdom and the
women there asked me to convey at the
first opportunity to the government the
need for more awareness more support
more research and more drug availability
can I ask the Prime Minister if he will
do that if he will help to bring that
support but also I have written to the
Scottish government asking for their
support if in his next meetings with the
first Minister he would mention it to
her
oh Mr Mr Speaker can I pay tribute to
the charity that The Honorable lady
mentioned for the work they do she's
absolutely right awareness is key in
tackling and identifying breast cancer
symptoms early one of the reasons why
we're investing more in Diagnostic and
screening tools to make sure that we can
detect more cancers earlier and treat
them and ultimately save people's lives
I I would be happy to pick up this
particular topic with the first Minister
when I next speak to her and ensure that
we are working together to improve
cancer services for everyone regardless
of where they live in the UK
well let's talk to Christine at shall we
I was quite Keen to get your pmq and
also the minute the moment of sort of
levity at the beginning as well because
you know you always get the kind of
Punch and Judy the very serious stuff
but I quite like the moment how are the
painkillers oh they're fine
um it was a damaged my shoulder earlier
in the weekend had to take some some
painkillers to get me through that but
it's funny now think I'm quite sensible
now okay good so we could have we say
the interview should go as as usual then
and so just talk what what did you
decide to ask that question in
particular then well it was on Saturday
um there's an exhibition which is
actually touring the country at the
moment it's a campaign called the darker
side of pink which is about metastatic
breast cancer which is secondary breast
cancer and of which there's less
awareness apparently than breast cancer
um and they are touring various
different locations throughout the
country with 31 clear plastic female
figures
um one to represent each of the women
who dies every day in this country as a
result of NBC but they also have on them
a q code and if you click on the cue
code you see the story of the woman that
that plastic figure represents and I was
just so moved and inspired by the women
the two women I met there who were
talking about you know their own
conditions and how they deal with it
that when I got the chance to ask the
Prime Minister today for help I took it
and I've already written to the Scottish
government to ask them to do uh more
because in Scotland there's no data and
without data you cannot really address
the issue because you don't know the
scale you don't know what it is it's
very very difficult what's the kind of
difference this is probably a very
ignoring question and I know you're not
you know I'm not really an expert on it
and but what is the difference between
secondary breast cancer and like
um well like you I knew nothing about it
really until I was speaking to them
which is kind of troubling actually in
itself
yeah
um and
um it's when the the cancer metastasizes
I think is the word I think it's into
your bloodstream and so it appears
somewhere else yes
um as a result of the the primary the
primary breast cancer and then the
prognosis is not good and um it's about
the treatments that are available and
um the women that I was speaking to have
been through several drugs
um and different types of chemotherapy
and one of the things they said to me
which really struck home was they said
that they had found it very frustrating
during the pandemic
that we had been so successful in coming
up with a vaccine
um for uh coronavirus very quickly much
quicker than anybody else anybody
thought because the process was speedied
up and we got it in what was it 18
months whereas normally it'd be five ten
years and what they would like to see is
the Food and Drug Administration in
America and the authorities here speed
up
um how quickly we can get drugs
um available for people in the way that
we did with coronavirus if we could do
it then they said surely we could do it
now for life-threatening and life-ending
conditions what did you make of the
prime minister's response to you
I thought
um I was if I say I was slightly taking
them back like you said
um the House of Commons can be very
punching Judy yeah
um and perhaps he thought when I stood
up he was going to get
um an attack about Dominic Robb or is
she said yeah or um Nadim zahawi and
various different things and when I
didn't
um I think he responded and claimed yeah
and I thought it was a very genuine
answer and it was a very appropriate
answer and he he showed I think in that
that he does actually appreciate
understand and and care about these
issues so I thought it was actually a
very very good answer he did come across
this year and actually that's why it's
quite nice to show because you know you
do get The Knockout stuff all the time
and like everyone fighting and I get it
you know there's big serious issues and
and it's a debating chamber but actually
it is quite important to show different
side as well as and I think that's
important because the public generally I
think I think the real dislike one one
another intensely and fight all the time
and only ever argue whereas very often
we get on with other people and from
other parties we socialize with them and
it's not really all nasty all the time
who's your favorite politicians from
different parties then oh who's a real
laugh
the real laugh well all my favorite
politicians are liberal obviously of
course but um Oliver was on earlier
Oliver died and I worked with Oliver
number 10 during the Coalition we were
both spad so I know Oliver is he's a
lovely person and he's great fun
um I love um I think Penny modern is
very good as I think she's got a kind of
sense of humor when she does business
questions yeah and I drink NRI maybe
yeah
um but all of us he's just he's just
lovely David Mondell from the
conservative party is lovely as well
he's great fun and I've been on visitors
and things with David you make friends
with people as well when you go to to
visit places on foreign trips so I think
in that answer today from mushy tsuna
you saw a bit of the the camaraderie
that they're often is in the comments
really interesting I had to talk a bit
of a different interview always nice
thanks very much for coming on the
program today you're watching at the
take we're live in Westminster up next
we are going to be talking to Sam coats
doing a bit of pace match analysis
foreign
[Music]
artists not just on the show but
actually on 100 days of British Scenic
it feels like a good time to kind of
Mark what's been going on what the
challenges are it's been a pretty
bruising hundred days but you've got
another thing that you want to point out
that's Lumi on the horizon that we
haven't really touched on in the program
yet that's right because you've got all
sorts of problems but I think there's no
bigger problem and I'm sorry about this
than brexit which is still a hangover
from the last five or so years and it's
to do with Northern Ireland here you can
see the the uh lack of hard border
between Northern Ireland and the
Republic and the European Union remains
a problem for the UK and the EU and
what's going on is the problems
involving Goods going from Great Britain
to Northern Ireland haven't gone away
and Richie soon wants to solve those
problems and in contrast to this trust
and in contrast to Boris Johnson he's
setting a very new tone I think we've
got a photo of just shows how different
Rishi sunak is when it comes to dealing
with his European Partners amazing it is
photo it is um and I'm told behind the
scenes that reflects the completely
different tone of ministers very
different to list for us exactly and to
Boris Johnson constructive they want to
be able to work together Rishi sunak
wants a deal on the Northern Ireland
protocol and the signs have been that it
might come soon there was a report in
the times this morning now it does feel
talking to all sides in the debate that
that report might be a little bit
premature I think we're looking maybe
the back end of February before you
could get some kind of deal but Sophie I
think that the deal if it comes over a
Northern Ireland protocol how you sort
out the last bit of brexit could be the
biggest moment of peril for the whole of
Rishi sunax Premiership why is that
because it could cement a deal that
keeps the UK Too Close Northern too
close to the European Union and if Rishi
sunak doesn't sort out these three
people and get them on side then he's
got a problem I love this these are
these guys you pick them out who are
they don't want it like that just
explain
to Sammy Wilson the hardest cool
brexiteers and most influential members
the dup you need the dup on side with
this deal in order to get storm one back
up and running but uh Richardson has a
problem if he doesn't get this guy on
board he's bill cash he'll convene a
Star Chamber to decide whether he likes
or doesn't like the deal and this guy's
the most famous brexiter in the country
Steve Baker there's actually a
description he's actually a government
Minister but the question is does he
agree with the negotiations going on
behind the scenes if Richardson gets
this Trio on board he'll do very well
but if he doesn't big political problems
I've got like 20 seconds on the program
but how many of these three are on side
right now do you think none oh dear not
great thank you very much Sam indeed uh
that is it for this the tape we're gonna
be back next week every week as well
Wednesdays at 9 00 p.m next up it is Sky
News at 10. thanks as always for
watching and see you next Wednesday
foreign
[Music]